[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance
he has been helped into the White House
by the evil of another nation and yet
all our politicians will do his promised
reviews and committees whose words will
be too measured and too late and now on
top of all else he will not listen to
the daily intelligence briefings I'm
like a smart person he said Sunday
factually correct incidentally perhaps
like a smart person but not actually a
smart person quote I'm like a smart
person I don't have to be told the same
thing in the same words every single day
for the next eight years he will not
attend the daily intelligence briefings
quote if something should change from
this point you immediately call me I'm
available in one minutes notice but he
would not necessarily believe the daily
intelligence briefings anyway after the
wave of reports about the intelligence
agencies confirming Russia's
intervention in our election quote these
are the same people that said Saddam
Hussein had weapons of mass destruction
no actually the intelligence agents kept
insisting there was no proof of such
weapons and they kept having their
reports thrown back in their face by the
administration of a president who was
like a smart person who knew better
quote the election ended a long time ago
and one of the biggest electoral college
victories in history the electoral
college vote has not happened yet if no
pledged elector changes his vote his
margin will be the 45th largest in
history in other words the 12th smallest
margin in history but he knows better he
always knows better
a CIA conclusion that the Russians
interfered with our sovereignty our
freedoms our elections to help put him
in office quotes I think it's ridiculous
I think it's just another excuse I don't
believe it
who was the last president who would not
listen to the daily intelligence
briefings how many Americans were killed
because george w bush did not listen to
the president's Daily Brief from the
intelligence community 2997 on 9/11 6731
more military in Iraq and Afghanistan
because what do you need intelligence
for if you're like a smart person and
still it is worse because from all that
we have covered in this base
for three months the day in October the
Trump slipped and repeated the same
mistaken attribution of a quote that a
Russian propaganda site had made the day
his confidant praised WikiLeaks and
intimated something bad was going to
happen to John Podesta
just before Podesta's hacked emails were
released by WikiLeaks all the evidence
of Russia's personal manipulation of
trump through his cronies like Paul
Manafort and Carter page and Roger stone
and now through Vladimir Putin's pals
like would be Secretary of State
Tillerson and the putrid congressman
Dana Rohrabacher because of all of that
and more suggests that Donald Trump
isn't just a stupid man's idea of what
like a smart man would be he is a man
whose assumption that he has the inside
information and everybody else is just
guessing appears to be based on
knowledge provided to him by Russia the
CIA said the russians hacked americans
you don't know that he says could be a
fat guy the CIA now says the russians
hacked to help get him elected i don't
believe that and so what i wanted a
landslide what happens when the CIA next
says the russians are absorbing ukraine
what happens when the CIA then says
Putin is so strong he's planning to take
back Alaska what happens when the CIA
then says there's an imminent terrorist
attack and attracts back to Putin what
happens when the CIA finally says
Putin's lost his mind he's launching
missiles you don't know that Trump says
I don't believe it the people should
know the truth they should know that we
have sustained a defeat without a war
the consequences of which will travel
far with us along our road they should
know that we have passed an awful
milestone in our history when the whole
equilibrium of representative government
has been deranged and that the terrible
words have for the time been pronounced
against our democracy thou are weighed
in the balance and found wanting and do
not suppose that this is the end this is
only the beginning of the reckoning this
is only the first sip the first
foretaste of a bitter Cup which will be
proper to us year by year unless by a
supreme recovery of moral health and
martial vigour we arise again and take
our stand for freedom
Winston Churchill said that more or less
in the British House of Commons October
5th 1938 days after Prime Minister
Neville Chamberlain at Munich gave the
Sudetenland in Czechoslovakia to Hitler
in exchange for a piece of paper
Chamberlain and much of the world thus
thought he had guaranteed there would be
no second world war just as supporters
of Trump think they have guaranteed some
kind of new freedom and of course more
money for themselves Churchill and only
a few others knew that in fact
Chamberlain had just guaranteed there
would be a second world war just as
those of us who recognize this Trump for
what he is know that the voters have
guaranteed themselves slavery defeat
economic disaster and the need to soon
or late save this nation and restore
freedom by extricate ourselves from a
Trump regime by whatever process
provides itself
Churchill was most prescient when he
noted that Munich was only the beginning
just as we must recognize that the
administering of the oath of office to
trump an event to be resisted by any
legal means is only the first and
smallest of a series of apocalypses
because just as in Churchill's time we
too have a Hitler no it's not Trump not
yet certainly not in this context anyway
the part of Hitler in our sad
reenactment of the months before the
Second World War is played by Vladimir
Putin Trump in this remake Trump is
Neville Chamberlain he knows better he
can see the strength in the foreign
leader he knows how to make a deal he
can handle him he can negotiate with him
he can hand him Our Lives our Fortunes
and our sacred honor he has already
helped hand Putin our secret right to
vote he will happily hand Putin a clear
path to the world domination he seeks
for Russia
he will just so long as Putin tells him
he's making a great deal and he's like a
smart person he will hand Putin this
country treason does never prosper
what's the reason wrote the British
author John Harrington four hundred
years ago and then answered it why if it
prospers none dare call
treason it's treason resist peace